like cyberpunk and solar Punk before it
motion Punk can be a genre an aesthetic
or a subculture it envisions a future
where natural human movement is given
priority I used a mid-journey to help me
visualize what this might look like
cities and towns would be filled with
opportunities to move these would be
optional but should be inherently firm
to encourage use
nature will provide many of these
opportunities and be seamlessly
integrated into the surroundings
movement is celebrated you don't get
funny looks for crawling down the street
common pastimes include dance gymnastics
parkour and calisthenics but nobody is
excluded this is about expression and
freedom and all kinds of movement are
valued
clothes are about function rather than
form
the role of the government is to support
this Dynamic activity creating more
opportunities for movement and
supporting our basic needs
the genre features a playful Rebellion
against the static sensible and
self-serious that's my vision for a
fitter Humanity what's yours